LET'GOTF
ETFRONT TONIGHT, HE'S INE ORIDA
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE, ANDE TENO
VICTY.USEND THE CULTURE OFSIS I
INADEQUATE FORIBNTURE. MUST LO D
BARD
E  DeSANTI
IES IN
FLORIDA TO BRAT THTHATT EDUCAT
EDRADITI OWNS , HE AO REPEATEDLY
THVE RLO ON
TWITTED WITH A
TECHNICAL ISSUE ANWAYET,ISARD W.
OFF.ETSO, YEAH, I SO. TO SIMPLIT
THE HE TIME IT, DeSANTIS
INBIDEN'S CAMPAIGN MADE LIT OF L
TWEETINGTHK
THEN THE LINK WENT TO IS.
MEANWHILE, TRUMP IS WATCHINGISSE
HE SNT TEARI IIDA GOVERNORST
POLLS, ATTACKING DeSANTIS AND
HI
AND OF COURSE E, YHIN MANY COVE
AND JOOMHAEA
ANNOUNCEMENT TONIGHT A
YOU KNOW, WHY THEY DID IT IN
THIS WAY?
N,HE
UNCONVENTIONAL AND HAVE MENT UN.
GETTING THIS EVE OFF THE  JUST
GROUND
MIRED IN GLITCHES.EYE OVERELINTK
A VERY DIFFERENT SPEECH THAT WEE
CANDIDATES WHO HAVE ANNOUNCE
HEN'UCH OF A
THE.
INSTEAD HE REACUSED ON THEN JOE
THE PROBLE HEN IN THE  PARTYUGH
OUT TRUMP BYTHEN HE EDL ET.
STEMO TE INARO YO
IS YOUOMAT
CAPITAL, I WILPRIDD STATES BECA
NO EXCUSES.
I WILL GET THE
>> Reporter: NOW, WHEN I JUMPEDE
HAVING A Q BETWEEN ELON
MUSK AND RON DeSANTIS AND ALSO
SACHS WHO WAS HOSTING TH
GLIGLITCHES TO THE AUDIENCE, THS
GOING TO BE THE OVY OF THENTOWEN
DeSANTIS IS A CANDIDATE R
PRESIDENT.
HE'LL BE RUNNING IBLICAN
PRIMARY AGAINST DO T ANDHENDTHON
GOING TO CONTINUE AFTETONIGHT'S.
>> INLY ISRIGHT,
OF COGH
YOU KNOW HE WAS ING
OTHERWISE. E IN POLNG
STEVE, TMUCH,
REPORTING FROM MIAMI.I WANTDAVI
TRUMP 2020 SENIOR CAMPAIGN
ASHLEY SO
FORMER NATIONAL COIT
ADVI 2YOINTOHEU'RE A MAJOR HERE.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OFeSS
DOING  ODID?
>> WEL THINK HE DID WELL,
AND I THINK IT SHOWS, LOOK, HE
Y'S ATTENTION,N, TRUMP, AND  TH
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING,
INTERNET.
WHAT HAPPENED TONIGHT IS HE LAID
A CORNER STONEOREW CONSERVATIVE
T NEW PEOP
T ON THI
PLATFORM, AND HE SHOWED THAT 'S
WAR CANDIDATES ARE
>> DAVID, WHATIN T
CO SEEE OFRE PROJECTION FOR
GET  DONE.
YEAH, SLISTEN, I LIVE F HAS BAN
INCREDIBLEER, HE'S DONA N'T KNO
WITNESSED ON
ISE BALLROOM THERE AND
DONE AN ANNOUNCEMENT, HE
HAVE HORRK
COVE IT.
IT WOU HU KNOW, IT
HAVE ACCOMPLISHED A ER THAN DOI
E
IT'S TO BE ABOUT TS
BUMBD H IV
HIM OF ARTUNITY.
ASHLEY, TONIGHT'S EVT WAS T ITN
HISTORY BYHE MODERATOR, AN IEE
L OF T TECHNICAL MAY HAVE OVERS
OUT, T GETT
ONTILLGIIT IS.
NL
E NEWSPAPEORG E
I THINK WHAT I SAW ODEDIO T  OT.
TONIGHWA A
COM RON ISHET
ON AND ON ABOUHO
N WAS TAIN AT THAT POIST SAYINGS
CAMPAIGN LNCNTEREST TI
AORTWITTER,  TOWN SE WHEN WE
I  TWITTERRE S BIASSED T SURINCH
EXPET,NG OTHER PEOPLE.
SO I HOPE DeS
HUGE CAMPAIGTION A
PRTWITTER,
AND, I MEAN, I, AND I  WILL F P
N TO W
IS SCH, IT WAS
SAR FROM R
DeSANTIS, QUESTIONING THE
TYS DURIG ABOUT  E'VERNOR WHO I
I CAN LOOK PAST THE FAEDAND IT
DIRECTION HE TRYING  TN'T TH
IT O OVERWHELMINPU
T  FAT THIS POINT, QUADRUPLE,
DOWN ON DIEYT ME P
LODAE CHILDREN.
OGEN JAMMI GENDEENTARYIS
PARENT
GHEGISLA, N THEY I THAT
NE G OLITICS,THEY GOTTHIS T
>> DAN, , HE'S CLEARLY
MAKINGS
F AND WHAT T TO BE
APPEAL, RIGHT?LL
ANIES  YOU'RE VERNOR.
HENG THAT, AND MAKING
CAMPAIGN.
IS THAT SMART?
ORS, ERI
ON WL TELL YOUN KNOW RON DeSANT
HE HAD ALREADY STARTED THIS FEUD
DECTED
FALL.
BROADER, IT SHOWS  T
GOVERNOR DA
O BIIS WILLI TO
FIGHT FOR, YOU K LICIES, AND FI
COER
THAT VOTERS ED HIM I
FAD  PSE FIG
WI ATYUP
TOCOMPS,
PPISE LOOK AT POLLS HE
CO, DeSANTIS HAD
FALLEN IN POLLS.S E WASN'TAR FP.
SAOST TEN.READ
HILLARY CLINTON, HEA
GROWING.
LARED
CANDIDATES.OUSLY NOWINN A IU AC,
CT THAT 'S YOU KNOW,T THE GHTH.
THEYE WOE PRIMARY ABOUT  TIME.
CAN DeSANTIS DD? YEAH,K,  D.
HE'S DE T JOB. IE WITH
R STATEMENT ABOUT THE DIANI , Y
THE GOVERNOR PUTR AN
INCREDIBLE COALITION T BEEN STIG
THIS STATE, AND I THINK THAT HE
PEOPLE'SIVES, AN  LAE GOVERNMENT
GUINK THAT'S S
HERE IN FLORID